Guys, today's video
is sponsored by NordVPN.
In today's video,
we want to find out
what ice melt is,
how it's different from salt,
and if you can melt it.
[Music]
This bag is ice melt.
It comes in
pretty large quantities
because it's usually used
for spreading on ice
and snow to melt it,
so that you can walk on it,
and not have snow
and ice to deal with.
And this is just regular salt.
This particular stuff is meant
for making ice cream,
but it should work pretty well.
For rock salt, historically,
has been used for
melting snow and ice.
But we now have
better newer compositions
that we call ice melt,
and those are thrown
on the sidewalk,
and you get rid of all
your snow and your ice.
It makes it safer to walk on.
So we want to look at a few
of the differences,
test which one
actually works better,
regular salt or ice melt,
and then we want
to see what happens
if we heat up the ice melt.
Will it melt
through snow better?
Can we get it into a liquid
that we just like
pour onto the snow,
and melt it all at once?
Lots of experiments.
Lots of things to learn.
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to take
some ice melt,
test its melting properties
versus regular rock salt,
and then see what happens to it
if we heated up or melt it.
All right.
First, let's just take
a look at these.
The rock salt here.
This is sodium chloride.
This is table salt.
Basically, it's just
larger chunks of it.
This particular ice melt
is a combination
of magnesium chloride
and calcium chloride.
Calcium chloride and magnesium
chloride are supposed to work
better than sodium chloride
for melting ice and snow.
That's the first thing
that we want to test.
We're going to get a tray
full of both of them,
and then sprinkle some
of both types of salt on top,
and we'll see
which one melt it faster.
But even before we do that,
let's throw some ice melt
into the furnace,
and get that melting.
[Music]
Okay, we've got two handfuls,
about the same size.
Regular salt that
Calli is holding,
and ice melt salt
that I'm holding.
Now, we're just going
to sprinkle them
over these trays of snow.
[Music]
I stand by mine
is prettier than yours.
I think you are correct.
While we're waiting
for that salt to do its thing,
what do you think we should do?
You want to build a snowman?
It doesn't have to be a snowman.
[Music]
Since its frosting,
you can lick your brush.
In snow, probably
not a good idea.
[Music]
Our snowman is
looking pretty good.
So before we take a look
at the results of the ice melt,
let's take a second
to talk about our sponsor
for this video, NordVPN.
NordVPN provides internet
protection on all
of your devices.
Computer, mobile,
both Android and iOS.
This is an app
that's super easy to use.
You login, and it connects
your internet through a server
in a different country.
This protects your information,
makes it harder
for people to get in,
steal your valuable IDs,
credit card information,
anything you might have
on your device,
and really keeps you safe.
There are a couple other things
that I really love
about it as well.
If you're using
peer-to-peer file-sharing,
that's something you
can do while protecting
your information,
and preventing anyone from
looking at what you're doing.
If you want to watch
a streaming service
from another country,
you can choose what country to
connect through through NordVPN,
so you can log on
and be like, hey,
I want to check out
this streaming service,
what they've got in Germany,
or England, or Russia,
wherever you want to watch from,
and it'll connect you
to the internet in that country,
so that when you log on to
your favorite streaming service,
it shows you the shows
available in that country.
It's a really cool program.
One of the things that
VPNs are most useful
for is security.
If you go to a hotel
or a restaurant,
and you want to use the public
Wi-Fi there, there are people
that want to steal your data.
They want to take all of
your info off of your devices.
Your phone has a lot
of information on you,
and if you log
onto a public Wi-Fi,
people can get in there,
and take it from your phone.
If you're using NordVPN,
your phone is protected.
People can't get in
and steal your data,
with your traffic being rerouted
through a private server.
Right now, Nord
has a deal going.
Check out the link
in the description,
or go to nordvps.com/random
to get 75% off of
a three year membership,
and use the code "random"
to get an extra free
month on top of it.
Ice melt.
That's exciting.
What does it do?
Oh, it's warm like summer.
[Music]
Does Olaf know
what snow melt does to snow?
I'm going to tell him.
Don't you dare.
[Music]
Whoa!
So, it turns out,
liquid hot ice melt--
He's fine.
Is not really good for snowman.
He's, he's fine.
Every--
This is fine.
He's okay.
Everything's fine.
Our generic unnamed
non-trademarked snowman
sustained a little bit of damage,
but I think we can
probably fix him back up.
He's..
He doesn't need fixing.
He's perfect just the way he is.
Yeah, untouched.
Absolutely.
He's beautiful.
I am wonderful.
Hooah!
She's become the villain.
[Music]
Do you want to break a Snowman?
Bye generic snowman.
Musical snowman
who loves summer.
He wanted to know
what happened with heat.
We showed him.
Our two trays of snow
have now been sitting there
with the salt and ice melt
in them for over an hour,
and what do you think?
They look fairly similar to me.
Fairly similar.
I think that the one
with the rock salt
is actually slumping
a little bit more naturally.
Where as you can see,
the pock marks
of the ice melt is caused here.
But you mentioned
that the differences
in cold can affect
how these are reacting.
It's true.
The rock salt itself is going
to help get rid of snow and ice.
The main advantage
of using the ice melt,
I mean, magnesium chloride
and the calcium chloride,
those are supposed to help
keep melting the ice
at an even lower temperature.
And what's happening here
is not melting the ice
in the traditional sense.
We actually have
a chemical reaction going
on that's lowering
the freezing point of the ice,
so that it no longer
is able to stay solid
at the same temperature.
The sodium chloride
disassociates into two ions,
but calcium chloride
and magnesium chloride
disassociate into three.
The individual ions
interact with the water,
and prevent it from
crystallizing so more ions,
means more water and less ice.
Once again, thanks to NordVPN,
the sponsor of today's video.
Check out the link
in the description,
or go to NordVPN.com/random
to get 75% off of
a three-year membership,
and use the code "random"
to get an extra free
month on top of it.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
The box up here will take you
to our latest video.
The box at the bottom
will take you to
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit that bomb
in the middle to subscribe,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.